Speaker 1: All right.
Let's go back to Discord David Pakman dot
com slash discord we're hearing from people
in the audience, the most important people.
Let's go to Keir from Scotland to Keir.
You're on the air.
Speaker 7: Hi, David.
I just I just wondered if you had any thoughts.
I don't know if you're aware of what's happened
in the U.K. today, but our prime minister
for the last four months started out denying
that he'd had any parties.
Yes.
Number 10 Downing Street.
Then, he said he didn't know that it was a
party.
And then and then he said, Oh yes, it was
a party, but I wasn't aware.
And now today he's been handed out and have
his wife and the chancellor of the Exchequer
have all been handed out £50 fines for breaching
lockdown rules, rules that they rule.
And they are all and there's over 50 people
who live in Downing Street and that have all
been handed out these fines and.
And there's he's got over a 75 percent dislike
with the public today and polls today.
And I was just wondering if you had any comment
on it or if you saw it because he's refusing
to resign as as chancellor.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Listen on the resignation.
I can't comment on the resignation piece.
You know, it's really for those.
I want to leave that to voters and others
in the UK to comment on.
But if there's anything good about this now,
we can look at it and say a 50 pound fine
is pathetically low.
And you know, sure, that's true.
But I think it's good that at least they're
being held to the standards where in some
places it would just be excused if that's
the punishment that should be assigned.
I'm glad that it's being assigned if the rules
were broken.
Also, like how much of this has to do with
the what is the definition of a party in the
UK?
Speaker 7: This is the thing is that he wrote
the rules, right?
The people who wrote the rules about what
our party was, but he doesn't seem to know
himself what the party is, which is absolutely
insane to me.
And just while I've got you here as well.
Do you think this is going to push perhaps
towards Scotland getting another and another
independence, this specific?
Speaker 1: Boris Johnson's party?
Speaker 7: You mean just the litany of things
that he's done over the last few years of
just lying in parliament and illegally prorogue
Parliament?
He lied to the Queen.
He's just I could let the list of things I
could see.
He's just I just wondering, is this going
to be, is this going to be the final thing
where the people of Scotland are just going
to say enough is enough.
We're done with you.
Speaker 1: I don't know what will be the proverbial
straw that breaks the camel's back, but my
sense for several years in reading about Scotland
has been that there is at least some clamoring
for another independence vote.
I mean, you tell me, is that the sense you
get?
Speaker 7: You think so?
Yes, I think there's a lot of people who previously
either didn't vote or to stay in the union
because of again lies told in the saying,
yeah, vote in the referendum in the run up
to the referendum, who have now you just just
had enough.
They don't.
They want the fed up with the constant lies
and just just the constant nonsense coming
out of Westminster and just want.
Speaker 1: I do wonder, I'm so I'm totally
sensitive to that.
And you know, it's it's the people of Scotland
that need to decide.
I'm not taking a position one way or the other.
I'm wondering if you like, are you aware and
does it concern you that there may be economic
difficulties in Scottish independence?
Is that a discussion?
Speaker 7: No, that's that's not really not
really a problem.
There's a lot of people who are like, Oh,
you take money from England and it's more
it's more complex than that because we have
a lot of offshore oil and there's a lot of
other ways like we can make a lot of money
out of tourism.
The real problem is is we can't have a referendum,
a legally binding referendum unless Westminster
says we're allowed to write.
Boris Johnson has outright stated he will
not allow that to happen.
Sure.
So even even if the Scottish MSPs decide that
they're going to have a referendum, you can
just ignore it and say, No, you're not getting
independence.
I don't care what the referendum you had said.
Speaker 1: Right, right, right, right.
That is a difficult situation.
Speaker 7: Yeah, yeah.
Very difficult.
Speaker 1: It doesn't really feel like self-determination
in that sense.
Speaker 7: And yet it's a bit of a sticky
situation, I don't know how you get that.
Yeah.
I don't care.
Speaker 1: I really appreciate your call and
for you filling us in on what's going on there.
Speaker 7: Oh, thank you for your time, sir.
Speaker 1: All right, there is Keir from Scotland.
A beautiful phone call, for sure